[Music]
thank you
wait welcome to the show it is an honor
to have you I've been meaning to reach
out for a very long time and I
appreciate you carving out the time in
your schedule well thanks very much Tim
it's great to be with you
and I suppose I should just say as a bit
of context the Catalyst for reaching out
was not one of your many TED Talks
although I've listened to men it was not
one River although I'm familiar with
that as well it was actually being
gifted the wayfinders by a friend of
mine and I suppose just as a way of
setting the stage if you wouldn't mind
could you explain the basic intent of
that book and the lectures that preceded
it and I'm curious since it was
published some time ago if there is one
story that you wish people would become
familiar with or chapter that you wish
you could
compel many many people to read at this
point in time
yeah well that's a wonderful
beginning Tim the wayfinders was a book
put together in a really wonderful
tradition in Canada called the CBC
Massey lectures
and it's a fantastic event where once
each year they pick what they call a
public intellectual and you're asked to
give five different talks in five
different cities before live audiences
those talks are recorded
for broadcast on radio three times
during this coming year and then the
lectures themselves are wrapped up into
a book and it's kind of an interesting
thing because as opposed to most public
speaking you've got a lot of things
going on you're recording for live radio
you've got a live audience and you're
also essentially delivering the lecture
that's already been published and often
isn't a lap of the audience if they've
bought the book but it's a great
tradition you know Martin Luther King
gave them I was the first Anthropologist
since Claude Libby Strauss
the wayfinders has a very conversational
style and I think that's one reason it's
been quite successful and particularly
for college students and the basis of
the book was really the mission that I
had at the National Geographic you know
I was very fortunate to be recruited as
the first class of what the geographic
was calling their explorers and
residents which is kind of an odd term
because none of us were ever in
Residence
but they wanted to demonstrate personify
that they didn't just
report signs say generated science and
so that they recruited seven individuals
Jane Goodall
Bob Ballard who found the Titanic Sylvia
the Earl the great oceanographer a host
of Incredible characters John Reinhardt
who the High Altitude archaeologist who
found the ice Maiden that perfectly
preserved Incan mummy on huliako and
they recruited me as a cultural
Anthropologist and was very much part of
a conservation Mission and the second
hundred years having told you about the
world now the geographic was going to
help you save the world and my mission
as defined in my contract was to change
the way the world viewed and valued
culture in a decade and the way to do
that was not through politics or
polemics but through storytelling
because you know storytellers as you
well know Tim changed the world and what
we were trying to share with the public
was kind of the fundamental revelation
of anthropology the idea that the other
peoples of the world aren't failed
attempts to being you you know they're
not failed attempts at being modern
every culture sure is a unique answer to
a fundamental question what does it mean
to be human and alive and when the
peoples of the world answer that they do
so in the 7 000 different voices of
humanity and all those answers kind of
collectively become our human repertoire
and so we also wanted to draw people's
attention to the kind of Haunting fact
that of those seven thousand languages
spoke in the day you Tim and I were born
by absolute academic consensus half are
not been taught to Children which means
they're morbid on the brink of
Extinction if not exhaustion and that
means in effect that we're living
through an era where half of Humanity's
intellectual social spiritual even
ecological knowledge is at risk and at
the same time this is the amazing thing
we're living through an era where
geneticists have finally proven it to be
true what philosophers and Poets have
always dreamed to be true that we really
are all brothers and sisters and I I
don't mean that in the spirit of hippie
ethnography I mean that studies of the
human genome shown without doubt that
the genetic endowment of humanity is a
Continuum race is a total fiction we're
all cut from the same genetic cloth
we're all descendants of Africa
including those of us who walked out of
the ancient continents 65 000 years ago
but here's the astonishing thing if
we're cut from the same genetic cloth by
definition we share the same genius and
how that genius is expressed is simply a
matter of choice and cultural adaptation
and so there is no hierarchy in culture
there's not that old Victorian idea you
know we went from The Savage to the
Barbarian to the Civilized of the strand
of London that Victorian societies you
know sat at the Apex of a pyramid that
went down to the so-called Primitives of
the world absolutely ridiculed by modern
science shown to be an artifact of the
19th century tree irrelevant to our
lives today and is distant from those
lives of the idea of clergyman in that
era who believe the Earth was only six
thousand years old so then the question
is how do you share this how do you
reveal this kind of wondrous thing about
culture to the world
you know you you have to show you can't
tell polemics are never persuasive so
the reason that book that book The Way
Founders it tells the story of the
Expeditions that we did to share this
message across the world
and so we deliberately and it wasn't
easy we didn't want to Simply go out as
so many ethnographic filmmakers tend to
do you know celebrating the exoticism of
the other we really wanted to go to
places where the beliefs practices
revealed this extraordinary universal
truth and I think you asked which was
the most extraordinary of all and it
would have to be the Polynesian
wayfinders yeah that blew my mind look I
mean this is just an amazing thing if
you think about it
even today you know members of the
Polynesian Voyage in society can name
250 stars in the night sky they can
sense the presence of distant trolls of
islands beyond the visible Horizon just
by watching the reverberation of waves
across the hull of their sacred canoe
the hokalaya this great vessel that is a
symbol of this Polynesian Renaissance in
the darkness in the hull they can
distinguish as many as five different
sea swells again moving through the
water distinguishing those who caused by
local weather disturbances from those
that pulsate across the ocean and and
can be followed with the ease with which
terrestrial Explorer would follow a
river to the Sea and each of these
chapters in that book Tim the subjects
also became films of course that we did
for the geographic we I kind of tried to
find it not a punch line but I kind of
lined it would sum it all up and so with
Polynesia it was very simple if you took
all of the genius that allowed us to put
a man on the moon and applied it to an
understanding of the ocean what you
would get as Polynesia
I found it so striking and I may be
using the wrong terms but that the
captain and the Navigator were too
entirely distinct total functions and
and that's a great example to me of
perhaps just a
a fundamentally different
way of viewing seafaring when you come
from a western lens and I I really
enjoyed that book I encourage everybody
to pick it up and if it's okay with you
I would love to actually segue to
another
culture another group yeah but Tim
before we leave Polynesia let me just
add one thing that just to clarify
things
for for your listeners
the amazing thing about this tradition
was that was based on dead reckoning
which means that you only know where you
are by remembering how you got there and
it was the impossibility of doing that
that kept most European transports
hugging the shores of continents until
the British solved the problem of
longitude with the invention of the
chronometer but we know that 10
centuries before Christ from an ancient
civilization called Lapita the ancient
ancestors of the Polynesians set sail
into the Rising Sun and this idea of
dead reckoning means and back to your
Navigator why he's not running the ship
because he he or she must sit monk-like
on the back of the vessel remembering
every shift of the wind every attack
every sign of the Sun the moon the stars
the birds the the salinity in the water
every one of these
empirical observation and the Order of
their acquisition and if that memory
chain is broken The Voyage can end into
disaster and all of this has to be done
by an individual who lives in a
civilization that lacks the written word
so all of this has to be placed in
memory over a three and four week Voyage
think about that tell me that is not a
form of Genius not just a form of Genius
but a form of endurance almost beyond
belief how how many hours of sleep on
average over that Voyage per day or per
night would that Navigator get it's a
great question because the kind of
catnap in a way
but they can't really do much more than
just cat mapping you know it's funny
this this idea of sleep you know we have
this we're so wired to the clock that we
feel that we've somehow done something
filthy or nasty if we only see four
hours so you know but many societies
around the world you know I I spent a
lot of time in the Arctic and one of the
things that's fascinating is that winter
is a time for Sleep the you know the air
of Perpetual darkness and summer the
light is Luminous all day long and kind
of it's not even appropriate to sleep
you kind of you know cat nap with your
dogs but there's just too much to be
done
so let's let's shift
just a bit or maybe entirely to the kogi
peoples of Northern Colombia you are
deeply deeply familiar and intimate with
Colombia and its people
I had the opportunity through a mutual
acquaintance Dr Mark Plotkin to meet a
mammal and a small group of kogi but it
was a very cursory experience and they
were very
select with their words and
communication
could you describe the kogi people
of Northern Colombia and perhaps just
paint a picture for people of of what
that culture and what that what those
people's
look like because I find them to stand
out at least for me amongst the cultures
I've been exposed to in a number of ways
yeah it's truly remarkable they live in
the Sierra Nevada de Santa Martha the
highest Coastal mountain range on Earth
that soars out of the Caribbean coastal
plain to about twenty thousand feet they
are all there are four indigenous groups
the kogi you mentioned the wewa the
ottawakos and the kankuano the cono in
the 19th century
kind of cut up I don't know a full
student deal with
the greater Colombian society and
endured a great deal of assimilation and
they're kind of struggling to get back
to their traditional ways but the other
three societies remain absolutely
extraordinary and in a blood-stained
continent you can almost say they were
never conquered by the Spanish fully
they are descendants of an ancient
civilization called tairona which
suffered immensely in the first Decades
of the Spanish conquest and the
survivors
fled into this mountain Massif where
they lived almost in total isolation
very little reference to them in the
colonial documents for 200 if not 300
years and it's almost as if they had
suffered so much that they made a kind
of collective vow never to screw up
again I think that accounts for their
intense religiosity many people call
them the Tibetans of South America but
they lived to this day
inspired by a ritual priesthood The
Mamas the sun priests and the training
for the priesthood is extraordinary it
was first reported in the 1940s by rikel
dormitov that the acolytes were taken
away from their families at the age of
two and three and then sequestered in
the shadowy world of Darkness for 18
years during which time they absorbed
the religious beliefs of their society
and it's their sincere conviction that
those beliefs those rituals those
prayers literally maintain the cosmic or
we might say the ecological balance of
the world and according to Reichel after
18 years in which the world only existed
as an abstraction the young acolyte was
taken out and taken on a journey and for
the first time in his life at the age of
18 or 19 he saw the Horizon he saw the
mountains he saw the sun and suddenly
the priest who has trained them all
these years says you know
it's that beautiful as I've promised you
it's yours to protect now this was
almost Tim a fable with an anthropology
because Michael never saw the ritual he
never went on one of those pilgrimages
to the heart of the world then an
amazing thing happened I first lived
with the ottawakos when I was a lad of
19 and 20. in fact when you mentioned
you know it's amazing I've now been
close with them for almost 50 years they
in fact the ottawakos call me their mama
Occidental so I I was once with
President Santos the Nobel Laureate the
first time he ever visited namasimake
and The Mamas had asked me to be there
to welcome him and I hitched a ride in
the presidential plane and and when we
got to the community
there's a kind of formal ceremony in
which the president introduced his
invitados you know his ministers and so
on and he got around to me and he
couldn't have been more generous with
his praise and his kind words but he was
interrupted by one of The Mamas who said
you don't have to tell us about that guy
he's our ambassador in North America you
know and so I have a very wonderful
relationship to them but here's what was
extraordinary
in one wintry day in Washington the
Colombian Ambassador then Carolina Barco
a good friend of mine turned up at my
office at the geographic with a
political leader Danilo viathania and
three mammals one from each of the three
cultures wewa kogi and arawako and they
were there because the BBC had made a
film and the arawakos felt they hadn't
had their say and they wanted to make
their own film so they'd come to me and
as I'm looking at this guy Danilo I I he
looks so much like an old friend of mine
so I pulled out a book of mine one river
which happened to have a photograph in
the front piece of one of the chapters
and I showed him and that was danilo's
father adalberto and who was murdered by
the paramilitaries and I said to Danilo
you know son you don't remember but when
you were a little infant I carried you
in my back for weeks up and down the
mountains with your father and he was so
touched by that and the connection was
so strong that he invited us to do what
I would have thought was the impossible
to actually go along on a journey to the
heart of the world and make a film about
this idea and and the pilgrimage and the
idea is very simple you you know the the
as you come out of the Sacred Temple
and what we discovered is they don't
stay 18 years in the darkness but 18
years in seclusion around the temple in
a ritual diet not seen women and then
they do go from the temple to the ice
and from the ice back to the Sea and
from the sea back to the temple
completing this sort of sacred
devotional pilgrimage of the Divine and
we made that film unfortunately at the
very penultimate stage of the pilgrimage
we were kind of ambushed by the farc and
we had to escape
and turn our cameras over to one of the
Weaver Lads that we had trained in
cinematography and with Incredible skill
he finished those segments of the film
so we actually had the entire pilgrimage
documented but I think there's a bigger
point to make about the Elder Brothers
as they call themselves they dismiss all
of us who have ruined the world as the
younger brothers and these are societies
that do not view the world
through an extractive Paradigm you know
they do not think that the world is just
a kind of a stage set upon which only
the human drama unfolds you know they
don't buy into the old descartesian idea
that all that exists is mind and matter
and that only things that can be
measured can exist that whole kind of
idea that we developed in the European
tradition that has now become so
dominant so powerful so ubiquitous but
it is not the norm it is highly
anomalous most societies interact with
the natural world through the kind of
metaphor of reciprocity some idea that
the Earth gives its bounty to us we owe
our Fidelity to the Earth and that's
very much how the mammals see their role
as representatives of the natural order
of things it's funny when I when I was
first asked by them to go and be there
when President Santos arrived one of my
close friends a man called Milo suddenly
something very profound he said you know
peace won't matter
and this is after 50 years of Colombia's
horrific War
peace won't matter if it's only an
excuse for the three sides to come
together to maintain a war against
nature it's time for us to make peace
with the entire natural world and as we
flew up to but
on the presidential jet you know from
Bogota
all of the president's aides were
peppering him with statistics for his
speech in the community that was going
to be broadcast internationally and I
kind of sheepishly put up my hand and I
said in Spanish you know president
Santos for the anonymous you know
statistics don't matter a rat's ass you
know what they care about is what's in
your heart and and then I told him what
Momo Camilla had said and president
Santos is an incredibly wonderful man
Incorporated that and made that the kind
of the theme of his speech that went out
that date of the world
I was very struck by and and I don't
want to spend too much time on this but
I'll just say struck by how Central
pagamientos offerings and payments seem
to be to certainly the mammals but
broadly speaking the kogi and I
appreciate all the contacts that you
just provided I would also love you and
we could spend five hours just
discussing what I'm about to bring up
but I also would love to ask you about
Coca so many people are familiar with
Coca as a leaf that is chewed or
something that is turned into cocaine
but could you talk a bit about Mumbai so
this is a word and something that has
come up
in my radius a number of times but what
is mambe where is it used how is it
prepared
coca is a generic term for two different
cultivated species and four different
varieties that have been exploited by
people in South America perhaps as long
as 8 000 years certainly five thousand
years and I should say that coke is the
cocaine what potatoes are to vodka
and the two main types of Coca
one is
called Colombian that's erythroxyl
novogranet Tennessee and the other is
the classic coca of the southern Andes
of Cusco and La Paz that is erythroxman
Coca now in pre-columbian times a
variety of that was taken down the
Amazon into the jungles of the Northwest
Amazon and this variety which is known
as erythroxyl and Coca variety ipadu is
cultivated vegetatively not from seed it
also has half the alkaloid concentration
and so in a very interesting way the
peoples of the Anaconda you know all
these extraordinary societies
I mean there's scores of these
extraordinary cultures
they've learned to take the leaves
roast them over
clay griddle and then rather than taking
the leaf orally and mixing some kind of
alkaline with it baking soda or
Limestone or ashes of certain plants as
you'll see in the mountains of Southern
Peru they add the ash of the leaves of a
tree known as yarumo and then they pound
the two together until you get a very
fine powder which becomes even more fine
when sifted through Palm fiber it's a
consistency of talc and with mambe then
you take the
the actual coca with a bone like this
this is a mambe bone right here and you
put the wad onto your mouth and you let
the saliva kind of soften it and and you
don't really talk or breathe the whole
works will just explode as a green cloud
and as it's moist you then lift it up
it's a quid and the advantage of course
is that by taking Coca in this way you
absorb the entire plant and thus all the
nutrients I mean one of the before I
just finished that then the other cocoa
the coke of the kogi that we talked
about that is erythroxyl novogranet
Tennessee variety novogram intensity of
the cook of Colombia and that coke was
taken down the coast to Trujillo in the
northern desert of Peru and that became
the preferred Coke of the Inca it's got
a little wintergreen oil in it it's
erythroxylin novogon intensive variety
trujiensei and that of course was a
preferred that to this day Coca-Cola
Imports each year by the ton allowing
their beverage to really be the real
thing the fascinating story Tim is that
I worked with Tim Plowman a protege of
my professor schulte's Mark's professor
in the 70s and we were charged to work
out the Botany of the ethnobotany
the ethnography of Coca and at that time
we thought that the coke of Columbia for
classic Botanical reasons was derived
from the coke of pru but now that we
have DNA we see a greater story it turns
out that these two sacred plants used
for 8 000 years revered as the Divine
Leaf of immortality by every culture in
the Andes all come from the same wild
ancestor a species known as erythrosan
gracelipes which grows along the Eastern
flanks of the Andes now that may seem
like Arcane botany talk to many of our
listeners but it's actually a miracle
because to have two revered plants
independently domesticated through a
process of artificial selection
thousands of miles apart and yet each
deemed to be sacred essence of the
Divine is unheard of no precedent in all
of the history of Botany and of human
cultures and so this is the the richness
of of Coca now the extraordinary thing
is that the efforts to eradicate coca
Fields began 50 years before there was a
cocaine problem in the 1920s physicians
in Lima in particular looked up into the
Andes and their concerns for the
well-being of Andean people was matched
in its intensity only by the ignorance
of Andean life and when they saw
illiteracy poor Sanitation
one social pathology after the other
they had to find a cause and because
issues of Economics land distribution
inequity came too close to challenging
the Bourgeois foundations of their lives
in Lima they had to find the evil source
and the source was Coca and they blamed
coca for every ill in the Andes and
through all those years these doctors
and Physicians and nutritionists never
did the obvious a nutritional study to
show just what this plant actually had
in it and when we finally did that in
the mid-1970s Andrew Weil Tim Plum and
Jim Duke at the USDA we discovered
horrified our backers of the DEA and the
U.S government because it turns out that
coca has a tiny amount of cocaine in it
absorb benignly as a mild stimulant by
the mucous membrane of the mouth
absolutely without harm the plant also
has more calcium than any plant ever
studied perfect for a traditional diet
without a dairy product it also is chock
full of vitamins it even has enzymes
that enhance the body's ability to
digest carbohydrate at high elevation
making it perfect for the potato-based
diet so in one simple nutritional study
that could have been done at any time we
put into Stark profile these hideous
efforts that are underway to this day to
destroy the traditional fields and we
showed that this was a plant that had
been used with no evidence of toxicity
let alone addiction for at least 5 000
years and so one of our big efforts
today is to decouple Coca from cocaine
and create a nutraceutical market for
the plant that will give
a legal market for the 150 000 families
in Colombia alone that depend on
cultivating coca for their survival and
also through taxes may just give
Colombia the revenue necessary to pay
the cost of Peace having drained its
treasury for 50 years to pay the cost of
a war only made possible by the sordid
profits of prohibition
so we may come back to Coca and as
you're discussing the nutritional
profile it makes me also think of the
role that coffee serves in in some
populations in the world but I would
love to
go to some well-trodden ground and this
is out of personal curiosity and also
because I think that many people want to
hear more of the background here and
then we're going to probably come to
discuss a number of mentors of yours but
I would love to hear you expand on TTX
and datura stromonium if I'm pronouncing
that right
and how you came across these two in
combination because datura I think the
tourist dramonium
also known as Jimson weed if I'm not
getting that yeah that's correct Grows
Right in my driveway in Texas it's it's
found in all sorts of places TTX a
little less so yeah right but could you
just to provide the background on where
you came across these two you know this
is an incredible story a kind of
assignment of a lifetime that would
completely change my trajectory you know
I had done a lot of work
in the Amazon
three years in fact through the Andes
and the Amazon
and I had studied anthropology but I
never really understood the real message
of anthropology until I went to Haiti
and I'll explain that in in a moment but
what happened
is that a very well-known
psychopharmacologist by the name of
Nathan Klein psychothermicology being
the study of the action of drugs on the
brain have been going to Haiti for many
years the psychiatric Institute bore his
name he had set it up on a close
colleague of his at McGill University
Heinz Layman at a former student Lamarck
du young who is now the director of that
psychiatric Institute and du young was
fascinated by the Haitian zombie
phenomena and of course by folkloric
belief the zombie is the Living Dead
it's an individual who has had their
soul stolen by sorcery
kind of propelled into Perpetual state
of purgatory said to be associated with
enslavement
and this was sort of something very much
from the realm of the phantasmagoric
but do y'all had been paying attention
and investigating every case that came
his way and finally he discovered this
remarkable story of a man called clarius
narcisse who in the early 1960s had been
misdiagnosed dead or he'd been diagnosed
dead by two Physicians both American
trained and and one An American in the
Albert Schweitzer Hospital in central
haitia an American directed institution
that keeps impeccable records and this
man claiming to narcissist later walked
into his village in about 1980-81
claiming to be the long-lost brother the
family members had no doubt but they
immediately told him to get lost and he
had to escape to the police station for
his own safety and when duyon and looked
into this he was able to secure death
certificates Scotland Yard verified with
their forensic expertise the
fingerprints that belonging to the
sister of the deceased East there were a
score of lines of evidence that suggests
that this man clearly had been
misdiagnosed dead and somehow turned up
in the realm of living in fact do y'all
went to the family members and put
together a questionnaire of intimate
information of the family background all
of which this man answered correctly so
the bottom line is that duyan and Layman
and and Dr Klein went public
saying they felt they'd found the first
zombie now that Drew their attention to
reports of
folk poison that was said to bring on a
state of parent death so profound it
could fool a physician now this poison
wasn't just mentioned in Travelers
accounts and missionary
Memoirs and an ethnographic reports it
was specifically mentioned in the penal
code of the country but we all had not
been able to find the poison he hadn't
secured a formula of it and this was key
to the whole question of the Haitian
zombie it was either something for the
realm of fantasy or if it was real there
had to be a natural product and if that
product existed that could make someone
appear to be dead such that they could
come back into the realm of the living
undamaged that had huge potential
medical applications as Klein saw it so
they came to Harvard schulte's said he
was too old to go but he said he knew
someone who could do the job and that's
how I was hired to go down to Haiti to
secure this poison now remember I I
wasn't looking for a poison that could
kill people lots of things can do that I
was looking for something much more rare
which was a poison that could bring some
to the state of apparent death so
profound could fool a physician and yet
the victim could survive and so I did
what one does I contacted a a sorcerer
he had been described by the BBC as the
Incarnation of evil he was nothing of
the sort he had a a house and a
bunch of Dominican women and he had been
a junior member of the Tonto maku but
you know I I was able to establish
through a little bit of kind of
theatrics a good relationship with him
and and very sorry wait let me pause you
for a second what was the group that you
mentioned I'm not familiar with it a
junior member of what group The Tonto
makut the Tonto makut Tonto in Creole
means Uncle maku means shoulder bag this
was the nickname for the volunteers of
for the National Security the militia
that was set up by Francois duvalier in
the wake of his presidential
election in 1957 and this is a pivotal
part of the story
because duvalier was the first president
in 100 years to say that Voodoo was
legitimate religion he had Voodoo
temples in the presidential Palace he
wore the costume of Baron samadi the
guardian of the dead of the graveyard he
played Voodoo like a charm and he used
the secret societies
as his base of power and from them as my
research would discover he created this
notorious Force the Tonto makut and it
means that if you misbehave they will
come and take you away in their shoulder
bag
and so I went out with Marcel after this
kind of bit of theater that we did to
kind of it was kind of funny I'll tell
you about it I want to hear about the
theater yeah
I went to him you know and with a good
friend of mine Max bovar who's when he
died was sort of heralded as the pope of
voodoo an amazing kind of conduit for
the outside world to understand Voodoo
and again as you say right off the top
Tim that
you know we have this idea of voodoo
from the movies it couldn't be more
wrong and we should just think for a
moment if we were asked to name the
great religions of the world what
continent would we leave out sub-Saharan
Africa and of course Voodoo is not a
black magic cult it's a song word from
Benin that means Spirit or God it's this
distillation a very profound religious
ideas that came over during the era of
slavery and then became you know
transformed within the soil of a new
world that's why you have hoodoo in the
American South Obi and Jamaica candle
and commune in Brazil and so on Santeria
in the Dr and of course Voodoo in Haiti
and Voodoo took a particularly strong
form in Haiti because as opposed to the
other countries I mentioned Haiti was an
independent black country the only one
in the world for a century gained its
independence in 1804 and at that time
much of its population the slaves had
literally been born in Africa so in many
ways you can almost argue that Haiti is
more Africa than Africa itself at this
point but at any rate
I saw Marcel and he made me the powder
but I knew the way he made it the
ingredients that it was kind of bogus
and so I instead of telling him that I
doubled what I had promised to pay him
and as I left the um for the temple I
mentioned I was going to try it on an
enemy I had in the capital I'd let it
know how it worked and then with a
deliberate piece of theater Max bouvard
and I stormed back a week later and
screamed and yelled at him that we had
nearly gotten killed that his powder was
worthless so you couldn't do a thing and
of course he then got Furious and he
went into the inner sank in the temple
and came out with a bottle a little vial
and he said if you don't in Creole he
said if you don't think I know how to
make poison drink this he won't walk out
of here alive and then all the Dominican
girls started going blah blah drink
drink drink and it was kind of a bit
tense and so I said to Marcel look at it
it's not that you don't know how to make
good poison I came all this way because
I know you can I'm just saying what you
made me is garbage and if you give me
garbage you'll never see me again but if
you give me the real thing you might
make a lot of money from us and then I
walked out and I went back the next day
and the proper ingredients for drawing
in the clothesline and then we went into
the inner sanctum the temple and he took
a bottle of raw alcohol with human
remains in it and all kinds of
animals and gore of one sort of the
other and he handed it to me and I took
a big drink and handed it right back to
him and he laughed and I think it was
the first time of many times that a
Haitian would say to me
what kind of white are you anyway and so
that was the beginning of my
relationship but the Fantastic thing and
and let me pause you for a second were
you not worried about drinking that no
no what was the expectation of the
ingredients
well it was just a ritual vessel of
magical all right things he's a sorcerer
a negative priest and you know it's all
been pickled and sugarcane alcohol I
really were part of it is it's not like
Macho it's actually a more subtle more
poetic more beautiful thing you know Tim
how how do you break down the barrier
between yourself and the people with
whom you find yourself living as a guest
and it's never bravado or Macho it's
actually always love and empathy and
letting people know that you believe
there's somebody you know and and it
seems so simple but you'd be astonished
how many people I encountered
particularly in Haiti including Dr Klein
who had no way whatsoever of hanging out
with those folks just couldn't do it
right and that's what I've been doing
all my life but the important thing is
from the Haitian point of view the
poison is not what makes a zombie and
that's really important and that
explains how I got the formula so quick
but the funny part of the story is that
it was Easter Sunday when I returned to
the United States through JFK airport
and I had this suitcase made of surplus
7Up tin cans that was filled to the
gunnels with human bones all the
ingredients in various forms I had a
live buffo marinus toad in my backpack
the biggest toad in the world 10 inches
across and I had no permits Customs
dream yeah you couldn't do this post 911
but I went up to this Customs agent and
I just said well let's just see what he
says so I opened up this thing so only
if you could see it and he slammed it
shut him and I'm not going to give you
exactly what he said because their
children listened to your podcast oh no
no this doesn't need to be family
friendly what did he say you can tell us
he literally said New York accent look
it's Easter Sunday I didn't even
want to work today I don't know
who the you are just get the
out of here
and that's how the zombie poison came
into America wow thank God for Easter
Sunday and that guy but then here's
where we get to your TTX I analyzed the
plants took the reptiles to the
herpetologists and all the various
creatures to the very Specialists and I
finally got around to the fish and I
went to see the ichthyologists in the
basement of the Museum of comparative
zoology and this was like out of a movie
and I say to this wonderful character
did you find anything in those fish and
he had his head inside a white shark and
as he heard me he bounced his head
against the teeth pulled his head out
and said I thought you were the poison
people and because our Museum was the
world center for the study of medicinal
and toxic plants and hallucinogens and
then he goes to the shelf and he doesn't
pull out the Journal of ichthyology he
pulls out a pocket book time store novel
and it turns out to be written by Ian
Fleming and it was either From Russia
with Love or from Dr No and at the one
end of one of those two books 007 gets
kicked in the shin by the bad guy and
dies and he comes back to life in the
next book because he's been kicked with
the poison to Trotta Toxin and that is
what blew open the zombie study TTX to
try to toxin because tetrotta toxin is a
big molecule that selectively blocks
sodium channels and brings on peripheral
paralysis dramatically low metabolic
rates and Consciousness is retained
until death and when you looked at the
symptoms of narcisse they match
perfectly the symptoms of victims of
fugu fish poisoning in Japan The Frugal
fish is a culinary delicacy the chef
must eliminate most of the TTX but not
all because he wants to connoisseur to
enjoy the pleasant after effects of a
mild intoxication but because some
people screw up lots of people have died
and there was a whole literature in
Japan and in the public in newspapers
case after case after case of people
nailed into their coffins by mistake so
this changed everything this suggested
without doubt that the sorcerers in
Haiti had found in their environment a
natural product that not only could make
some appear to be dead but had done so
many times in the past so then you had
to ask what really is a zombie who's
controlling the process and the end I
was able to become the first person from
outside of Haiti ever to be initiated
into the biz Uncle shampoo the secret
societies they produce the Tonto makut
and I was able to at least suggest that
zombification was a form of ultimate
social sanction
in which the individual lost their
personal autonomy and their physical
freedom and became kind of cast into a
state of purgatory that was in a sense
worse than death so just before we leave
zombies the whole purpose of this was
let's define the drugs used to make
zombies because no drug can make a
social phenomena but rather to take a
phenomena that had been used in an
explicitly racist way to denigrate an
entire culture in its religion and to
try to make sense out of sensation and
so if the scientist sent me to Haiti to
find the chemicals used to make zombies
I found myself instead studying the
psychological social historical
political dimensions of a chemical
possibility and that's what made the
research so exciting you know the
pursuit of that little preparation
opened up these historic and
ethnographic Vistas that no one had had
seen before
I have two questions related to this and
I'm sure we could have dozens more but
there are so many other things I'd love
to chat about but two two follow-up
questions the first is what role if any
does the datura play in this entire
process and they're documented deaths
every year in the United States at least
related to people who attempt to DIY
some type of
trip from datura so the role of detour
if any and then secondly
and this is based on a somewhat
fragmented recollection of watching some
type of news program that was reportedly
covering this social phenomenon of
zombification and my impression from
that was that some people remain in
servitude for other people as zombies
for an extended period of time and I'm
wondering if there is what are the
primary contributing factors to a
situation like that one of the things
you always have to do in this kind of
research is separate what we might call
the emic from the attic which are
unnecessarily technical terms in
anthropology the view from within the
view from without you know like why
don't the people in India eat
Charles was prohibited by the scriptures
but also they need the oxen to work the
fields you know those would be the two
points of view and first let me answer
your question about datura datura is in
a solenacy the potato family the family
of choice of Black magicians around the
world the treat actors the brugmansias
in South America are known as the
Jaguars intoxicants
the tree of the evil eagle and these
plants have in them powerful tropaine
alkaloids Scopolamine and atropine in
particular that induce a state of
psychotic delirium with visions of
Hellfire a burning thirst
Amnesia a sensation of flight
these are incredibly dangerous and
horrific
plants that the shaman and the Andes
take only if everything else fails
almost with the idea that just in
touching the realm of Madness they might
achieve illumination and
what's interesting and going back to the
victims of tetrata toxication in Japan
if you eat fugu fish and you get
poisoned and you're put into your coffin
and you're lucky enough to be rescued
you come out of the coffin and you say
oh that's terrible what a mistake I'll
never eat Fugu again but that's the end
of it right but remember the Haitian
doesn't sit around questioning whether
zombies exist he or she knows in the
fiber of their being that they do and
here she knows why a zombie is made a
form of punishment
within the traditional culture and so we
don't know exactly what might or might
not occur we know that tetrotoxin
reaches a crisis in about six hours and
if you survive that crisis you have no
physiological damage whatsoever but of
course in the case of the Haitian zombie
whether the individual is symbolically
put into the ground
placed behind a shade or or hidden from
view whatever when they come out of the
Tetra detoxification
they know what's happened to them and
they're in a state of incredible
suggestibility and and fear and what the
datura may serve it's known as the
Kunkel zombie the zombies cucumber and I
was at least told by many informants
that at that point of disorientation the
victim is given datura which must be an
extraordinary horrific experience and
one that would sort of seal the
psychological
conviction that he or she had in fact
been punished in this way now when you
mentioned the idea of slavery well
there's no incentive to create in Haiti
a force of indentured labor but again
critically given the colonial history
slavery implies a destiny almost worse
than life itself and by the same token I
mentioned earlier that they don't
believe the poison creates a zombie what
a zombie is is to make a zombie I have
to capture Tim your little good Angel
your soul the soul that makes you Tim
Ferriss as opposed to the soul that
makes me way Davis not the soul that we
both share that all sentient beings
share but the
saw that creates your personality that's
why a zombie appears comatose the fear
in Haiti is not of zombies it's of
becoming a zombie and so so I once asked
a voodoo priest for example if it was
just a matter of returning the soul to
the victim could that be done and the
person made whole and the man who I
asked that question was the great
emperor of the secret society he would
have been head of the Tonto makut for a
fifth of the country I once asked their
artist During the Revolution he had ever
killed anybody he said I never killed
any people just enemies no so I asked
him my art you know couldn't you just
give the soul back to the person and he
said yeah you could do that but on the
other hand if you were a woman would you
want an ex zombie to ask you to dance
and of course what he was getting at is
that a zombie becomes a total Pariah now
remember what I said about narcisse when
he first went back to his village nobody
doubted that it was the long lost
presumed to be dead brother but did they
welcome him with open arms no no they
told him get the hell out of here
because he was he he had died socially
he had died spiritually they wanted
nothing to do with him and that really
is what a zombie is all about yeah thank
you for that and part of the reason I
was asking about the datura is I I do
have some familiarity with with
brugmansia and I've had some exposure to
the you know the awaken or the aguarunas
to use it pretty extensively for
not just dark purposes or power purposes
but for for many different conditions
but
my understanding is that also organized
crime I want to say in Colombia for a
period of time was using brugmansia
seeds which I think they called
burundanga they would pulverize and say
someone with a map would walk up to a
mark and say could you tell me where
this place is blow the powder into their
face at which point that person would
become highly suggestible and also have
developed Amnesia so you could say take
someone back to their own apartment ask
them to help load their things into a
truck they would have no recollection of
this even though they would be coherent
interacting with security guards and for
that reason I was wondering if perhaps
the datura was used in a in a similar
fashion to increased suggestibility
you're absolutely right right on Tim the
word datura the name of the genus comes
from ancient India bands of criminals
known as The daturas Who used it as a
knockout drug well I did not know that
wow I was once in Santa with Steve in
with a Colombian this Australian kind of
hippie Guy this is back in the early 70s
and he spoke about how he ate a bunch of
tree datura in his hotel and on the
coast and ended up walking around the
naked The Barranquilla a public market
for five days before he was finally
arrested and at our table Tim there was
a wonderful Colombian hippie girl who
looked up at me and said I know that
market I wouldn't even buy a mango there
but I'll tell you in my book Magdalena
about the the Great River of Colombia
there's a story of my good friend
William Vargas who was on his way to
University and these stories like you
recounted are part of Travelers lore in
Colombia but I had never met anyone who
had actually endured this and someone on
a bus offered him a cake or cookie which
he ate and that was the last thing he
remembered and he came to me four days
later in a kind of a psychic
having lost everything that he owned and
and had his entire kind of psychological
State shattered so these are very
powerful
drugs indeed
so I guess there are a few lessons
number one don't take or accept candy
from strangers everybody listening and
do not play around with these plants and
molecules they are they are no joke and
can do a tremendous amount of damage so
I would like to rewind the clock a bit
and you mentioned Richard Evans
schulte's I've had a number of
discussions about him on the podcast
before so he may come up but I would
actually like to invoke a different name
which is David Mabry Lewis if I'm
pronouncing that correctly could you
please describe who he was and what you
learned from him or what lessons he
imparted to you yeah that's the one I'm
so glad Tim you did that
you know obviously I was so incredibly
fortunate looking back
you know I was an undergraduate at
Harvard I got my PhD at Harvard but I
began as an anthropologist and David
Mayberry Lewis was my undergraduate
tutor he was one of the great
americanists he had
traveled Into the Heart of Brazil in the
1950s to live amongst the
savante and before that the sharente who
at the time were said to be the most
feared
indigenous groups in Brazil
and he was a great humanist and while I
was with him he created
cultural survival with his wife Pia and
he absolutely lived in a way although he
wasn't really a boazian because he was
from the British tradition of social
anthropology but he absolutely believed
that activism was an integral part of
the anthropological Endeavor you know
when you have languages
disappearing when you have indigenous
people suffering the predations of the
rubber era there's a moral obligation to
both tell their stories and to work with
them I think as liaison a conduit to the
world
facilitating or amplifying their voices
bringing their concerns to the world and
that was something that I had in the
fiber of my DNA because of my
association with David I was also very
fortunate as you mentioned to fall into
the orbit of Professor schulte's but
Professor schulte's was a man of action
and deed in 18 years of studying with
him I don't think I ever had an
intellectual conversation he would say
things to you like there's one River I'd
like you to know knowing full well is
the process of getting to that River
would involve experiences guaranteed to
assure you that if you emerged out of
the force that Confluence alive you'd be
a wiser and a more complete human being
but schultes was not a man of ideas he
was he was a botanist that's what he was
a plant Explorer and I I loved Botanical
exploration largely because it provided
the conduit to culture you know if you
want to live with the Inuit in the high
Arctic you better become a hunter her
because that is a measure of a man you
know if you want to engage the priests
in Haiti you have to serve the law
you've got to become part of the circle
of voodoo otherwise what are you doing
and of course in the Amazon the plants
become the perfect conduit to culture
you're not turning up at some maloka and
saying I'm here to study your sex life
if someone turned up at our doorstep
like that we call the police but
studying the plants makes so much sense
to those For Whom the plants are so
important at the same time most
ethnobotanists of my generation were
notoriously uneducated when it came to
the nuances of anthropology and
ethnography and I was very very
fortunate
in having in David
a mentor who carried all the way through
graduate school I taught more courses
for David than I did for schulte's and
in fact my ideas
that in the wake of all my Botanical
research I actually kind of discovered
in the wake of the Haiti work that what
I was really interested in was culture
as opposed to plants you know I always
still use plants to inform much of my
writing but it was the ethno part of
ethnobotany that intrigued me and and in
that sense
all of my ideas that I have been
exploring you know through the 13 years
of the geographic the decade as a
professor of anthropology at the
University of British Columbia
everything traces back to David and I
you know on the subject of mentors I
think this is so important for young
people listening to this broadcast you
know I grew up in the simplest of middle
class homes
my father's spirit in many ways been
broken in the war
as had my mother in a different set of
circumstances there was not a lot of
there was a lot of love but not a lot of
activity
creativity and it was very clear to me
that that I had to get out and I began
a very young age jumping off cliffs and
as Terence McKenna always said the great
lesson of life is that when you do that
you don't land on rock you land on a
feather bed the world exists to lift you
up not beat you down you know Jim
Whittaker the great climber a good
friend of mine said that if you're not
living on the edge when young you're
taking up too much space but what I
found myself having to do Tim was fling
myself into the arms of mentors and
those mentors could be an old gitsan
Elder who recorded mythology with and
hunted with for 40 years it could be an
engineer who taught me how to
you know understand the the complexities
of industrial logging when I spent a
year in the bush I've always believed
that nothing is beneath you nothing is a
waste of time unless you make it so you
know a cab driver can have as much to
teach you as a professor at University
if you're open to the possibility and I
always found that if I just gave myself
fully to these mentors like schulte's
like David Mayberry Lewis like Dr Klein
and many that I've I've had the
privilege to engage since then you know
I was able to
become the most important thing which is
the architect of my own life and this is
what I say to young people you know be
patient never compromise give your
destiny time to find you
and bitterness always comes to those who
look back on a life of choices imposed
upon them from the outside and you may
not make all the right decisions but if
you own those decisions they all become
the right ones because together they
become the path of your own creation and
you become the architect of your own
life and that is something so very
important and in that Spirit Tim I try
to do everything I can to help young
people I answer every email and I get as
you do thousands of emails from young
people and very often what they're
saying they may have a specific question
but what they're really saying is not
just how can I be youth they know they
can't be me but what they really want to
know is how can I live a life of
authenticity how can I live a life where
I'm not strapped to a laptop at a desk
in a cubicle how can I find a way to
monetize the creativity of my own life
you know how can I make myself and the
act of being alive my vocation
recognizing that any job one has is just
a passing thing a kind of a filter
through which to see the world and only
for a time and the real challenge is to
make the art of life itself your
vocation and I always answer those
because you know if you don't answer
it's not a neutral
gesture it's a slap in the wrist they're
reaching out to you and all you have to
say is wonderful idea Charlie go for it
your friend
and that takes about as much time as as
deleting the message and I learned that
from schulte's you know I'll tell you
one wonderful story
Schultz is if you the most famous
Botanical collections of schulte's and
Mark would certainly confirm this were
between 1950 and 1953 when free of the
rubber emergency he was free to collect
medicinal plants he described the use of
2 000 medicinal plants previously
unknown to science and with them on all
those collections it was a man called
isidoro Cabrera now when you do botany
and you collect plants the senior
botanist name goes first so Tim Plowman
and Wade Davis Plowman and Davis and
that's how it you do it on the specimens
it's kind of a formal thing but you
never are said to put an indigenous
helper on the label as if he's an equal
to you but schulte's did and he met
izidoro when izidoro's Farm had been
burned in the war his parents had been
murdered he had no food he was
absolutely nothing and he ended his life
full professor of Botany with multiple
honorary degrees and before he died when
I was writing the book One River I went
to see isidoro in Kali and I said
Professor I want you to think really
carefully I want you to remember the
first moment you met professor schulte's
in the fourth in the Macarena what was
it like what did he say and he looked at
me very pensively and then he suddenly
there was a twinkle in his eye and he
said he looked at me like I was somebody
isn't that beautiful Tim that is
beautiful and in class riddled Columbia
at that time for a Harvard Professor to
do that and and it made that young man's
life pulled him out of misery gave him a
career and a great gift to Colombia
what a story and I want to come back to
I suppose
frames and lenses for a moment and also
Jim Whittaker so for those who don't
know the first American to summon
Everest if my research is not not lying
to me and I'm looking at an excerpt from
alumni stories on the
brentwood.bc.ca website and he comes up
and there's a line that I would like to
explore because I think it's Maya
Angelou if I'm pronouncing her name
correctly said that courage is the the
mother virtue that unlocks all other
virtues because of the effectively I'm
paraphrasing here but at the breaking
point you need courage to enact or to
enable those other virtues and there's a
line here and I don't know if it is
Jim's or yours but either way I would
love for you to expand on it pessimism
is an Indulgence Orthodoxy is the enemy
of invention Despair and insult to the
imagination and I I want to bring this
up because
it strikes me that a lot of people not
just very young people but many people
overall feel a certain psycho-emotional
malaise right now a sense of overwhelm
that has led to
pessimism or nihilism and it seems to be
the optimism optimism is the unlock here
so could you elaborate on the pessimism
as an Indulgence and so on in that line
yeah that was actually my line not gyms
you know people are always asking we're
always asking each other are you
optimistic and I kind of feel like
how can you not be optimistic I mean
that's the purpose of life itself and if
you're a father you absolutely have an
obligation to remain hopeful and
given how many gifts we have
surely pessimism does become something
of an Indulgence you know you know we
are we're also caught in the present
these days you know so little sense of
history and we forget how much we've
achieved you know in but when you think
about it Tim in my lifetime women have
gone from the kitchen to the boardroom
people of color from The Woodshed to the
White House
gay people men and women from the closet
to the altar when we think of the
environment when I was a young kid just
getting people to stop throwing garbage
out of a car window was a great
environmental Victory nobody spoke about
the biosphere biodiversity now these are
terms familiar to school children so
what's not to love about a world capable
of such social Transformations such
scientific genius you know just think
about
that moment on Christmas Eve 1968
when Apollo went around the Dark Side of
the Moon and emerged to see for the
first time in human history not a
sunrise or a moon rise but an earth rise
and in that incredible moment we
suddenly saw the Earth as it is not this
infinite Horizon but a fragile
Blue Planet as the astronauts famously
reported floating in the Velvet void of
space and I think everything has changed
with that you know like a flash of
Illumination it swept over the world you
know we never will think again about the
natural world in the same way we did
before that vision and even today as I
mentioned earlier I think the
revelations of genetics showing us
indisputably that race is a total
fiction well that
hasn't really gotten into the Zeitgeist
yet as the moonshot has but it will and
I think that
we're living through
extraordinarily exciting times
an extraordinarily challenging times but
as I say to all young people what
generation has ever come of age in a
world at peace a world without troubles
you know it's it's very interesting one
of the ways I Tim keep my optimism you
know my my dad wasn't a religious man
his Spirit was broken in the war I never
saw the inside of a church in his
presence but he did believe in Good and
Evil and he used to say to me there's
good and evil in the world take your
pick and get on with it and it was
incredibly wise because we had this sort
of thing in the Christian tradition
particularly that if we just wait long
enough Good's gonna triumph over evil
and we'll all somehow be dissolved and
the Rapture will ain't gonna happen and
famously in the medieval times if you
ask the obvious question if God's
all-powerful why does he allow evil to
exist you were burned at the stake for
heresy right but in the Indian tradition
The Vedic tradition by contrast when
Lord Krishna was asked said very
question if God's all powerful why does
he allow evil to exist in the universe
Lord Krishna said to the disciple to
thicken The Plot In other words good and
evil walk hand in hand you're never
going to lose one you've got to take
your side and the the purpose of life is
not to triumph over evil but keep
pushing the wheel of Justice forward and
when you realize that that is the end
point you then never expect to win and
if you never expect to win you're not
disappointed when you lose and because
of that you can keep fighting with the
same idealism the same energy when
you're 69 years old as I am today that I
had when I was 20 years old and marching
against the war in Vietnam
I'd like to discuss rights of Passage
and specifically we don't have to
necessarily focus on this but this this
is something that often ends up on my
radar of Consciousness because I have
many males in my audience and there
seems to be a distinct lack of rights of
Passage for men in most
westernized Societies or many
westernized societies and I would love
for you to describe a chapter in your
life and I'm most certainly going to
butcher this pronunciation but spots
easy
oh did I get that right yes but it's
easy red goat so could you explain what
that is rights of Passage exists all
around the world for a very specific
reason it's not a coincidence
or an accident that they involve pain
you know whether it's scarification
whether it's the severing of the
foreskin whether it's the pain of ordeal
the ingestion I mean for example the
Algonquin speaking of datura their
initiation right was to put the young
Lads in the long house seal it shut and
make them eat datura for two weeks oh my
God so that they would forget what it
was to become boys to learn what it was
to be meant but the reason all these
ordeals that you know so much about
Vision quests Etc have pain is because a
message has to be clear this is the end
it's not about the twiddling of thumbs
we are passing on to you the obligation
of adulthood you now hold the destiny of
our people in your hands this is not
trivial you best be prepared and I think
whether it's with women who go through
their own rituals which are always sort
of timed to the first Menses or the
first period the fertility transforming
a girl into a woman a potential mother
or it's a boy
proving his manhood now this has become
rather you know
frowned upon in our kind of politically
correct woke world but the truth is
young men I've never known a young
lad who didn't want that challenge it's
that idea of proving oneself not in a
gratuitously match away but literally in
a kind of organic way of grit and
courage and strength and I think that's
why I mean for example I've got very
close friends in the Navy Seals and they
all have a kind of a calm confidence
because they've been on what Joseph
Campbell called the hero's journey and I
think those of us like myself in you
know brought up in a society that we did
not have obvious Outlets we created our
own Heroes Journeys and for me it was
always either through work or travel you
know
you mentioned spats easy well you know I
was living
on Haida Gua in Northwest British
Columbia in the mid 70s and
I was very much critical of industrial
clear-cut logging but I felt that I best
learned something about it so I lied
about my credentials and managed to hire
on as a logging forestry engineer in one
of the toughest logging camps in the
west coast of British Columbia where I
stayed a year and I learned everything
about the business including the
corruption and it was a fantastic
experience because I also learned that
the men and women fighting off hunger
with the chainsaw were not my enemy
I learned that in all of these conflicts
particularly around resources there are
never any enemies only solutions but I
kind of Escape that camp taking a job as
the first park ranger in what had just
been created Canada's biggest roadless
Wilderness Park in my job description
was deliciously vague Wilderness
assessment and public relations in two
four-month seasons I saw 12 people there
was no one to relate publicly to and
these travels to South America
and even in Haiti you know
you have to understand that during the
course of that research
it turns out I never knew who was paying
for it all right
and I'll tell you if you'd like a story
of the night I had to light myself on
fire
to get up well I can't say no to that so
yes please well remember I said I became
very close friends with Marcel Pierre
and we were like brothers by the end of
the many years I was there and his wife
was down at uterine cancer and he was so
sad he came to me and I bought all this
blood for her and she still was dying
and I took him back to get a tap tap and
for once I was dressed like an American
Tourist and I didn't know what is that
tap tap oh What tap Taps is local bus in
Haiti I see and I didn't have I went in
my little Jeep and I didn't have my
wallet or any money and I got a flat
tire after I dropped him off and I said
to this guy at the side of the road who
fixed tires manually I said can you fix
my tire he starts fixing my tire then I
say Creole uh Missing me cold
like I've got no money and then he said
and he started hassling me and I just
wasn't in the mood I should have not
done this but I took his hand and I gave
him the secret society handshake and
then he blanched back and he said then
he said again what kind of white are you
and then we had a big laugh and he said
oh I gotta again grow that guys as well
we got a big thing happening and I had
broken down by chance right by a bizango
champwell secret society Temple so I
went back that night for the first time
unescorted by a powerful voodoo priest
and the ceremony begins like any
ceremony with the invocation of leg by
the spirit of of communication and the
dances are just Voodoo dancers but then
at midnight you hear the fat cash the
whip crack and the con trumpet the
symbol of the revolution and blow and
then the order goes out soldiers of the
night sane skin so that the newest and
everybody goes the hundreds of people go
into this Temple and emerge in these
Anonymous black and red robes and at
that moment six men came and grabbed me
and flung me into a chamber and I rolled
around in the dust and I looked up and I
was looking at a table of Emperors of
the secret societies who wanted to know
how I knew what I knew and I shared with
them the iconography passwords
handshakes
but it was all too much and too little
at the same time and it was a very
awkward moment and I had to do something
I was there by myself
and there's always a human skull with a
candle burning with a bottle of raw
sugarcane alcohol the base of the
potomito which is used as a libation not
to drink so I just thought I better do
something so I very deliberately went
over took the bottle and poured the
alcohol over all over my body my back my
hair everything and then very
deliberately went to the candle and lit
myself on fire
and as I flamed like a torch remember
this isn't kerosene or diesel it's just
like doing the same thing with lighter
fluid there wasn't any danger except I'd
lose my eyebrows and but while I was
still a living torch I went over and
offered the secret society handshake
again to each of the men they loved them
cracked up laughing and after that I
couldn't go buy that crossroads without
getting flagged down
you know and I became very friendly with
that Temple actually well okay so hold
on I mean that's a hell of a party trick
so how did this occur to you and I guess
you just had knowledge that that
wouldn't pose any grave danger I
certainly wouldn't I mean having your
body on fire seems dangerous but no it's
you must have lit your fingers on fire
with lighter fluid when you were a boy
I I haven't I mean maybe I should I
never never say never no maybe it's a
Canadian thing you know it's like you
know it's like I don't know you know
there's these moments and and I don't
mean in any way because I I keep saying
it's empathy and love it's not bravado
but I remember when I was 14 you know my
mother was a
a modest but determined Canadian woman
and she worked all year as a secretary
to raise enough money let me join a
group of kids a language teacher was
taken to Colombia and I was really lucky
because I I was billeted in the
mountains and I never saw the other
Canadian Lads and many of them got what
the Colombians called mamitis or
homesickness and I felt like I just
finally found home I got drunk for the
first time and kissed a girl I was in
heaven but there was this real bully and
there was a real bully in the valley I
was 14 and he was 17 or 18. and he kind
of terrorized even the bad guy
terrorized all the kids and one day he
challenged me to what they would do is
they put a cigarette you put your arm
forearms together put a lit cigarette in
the middle and the first one to drop
their arm is the loser and he put the
cigarette on and I told him this is
stupid it hurts you know but he didn't
understand that that cigarette could
have burned through my arm before I
would drop my arm and of course I didn't
drop my arm and if eventually he had to
drop his arm
and that was kind of a gift for me to
him because he was never the same again
after that he was a different character
he he didn't have to do that anymore and
to this day I still have that huge scar
on my forearm but you know I don't ever
regret having done that you know and
part of the what is wonderful about
doing this kind of field work
is a dance of culture you know you know
how do you find the Rhythm it's like
dancing with a woman for the first time
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
but what how do you you know I always
say to Young students setting off to the
field you know
what you need to do is just act like you
would if invited to someone's home at
Thanksgiving you know be polite have
good manners self-deprecating humor a
willingness to eat what's put in front
of you and sleep where you're asked to
sleep I mean Tim food is power it's
amazing how many people will so
crudely refuse a gift of food you know
if you're being given food almost
anywhere in the world it means some
child is probably not eating that day
and even if you know and there's been
many times when I've known because of
the circumstances that if I eat a plate
offered to me without doubt I'll
contract Giardia or amoebic dysentery I
always eat the food because you can
always treat the illness you can never
rekindle the trust that you've shattered
not just between you and the person but
between that person and the next
Outsider who will come along
I'd like to
jump back to Rites of Passage for a
second because
I do feel like
young males pay the price for the void
of the no rights of Passage and women
too but they do have that inbuilt as you
pointed out rite of passage whether it's
formalized in some type of societal
context or not I'm curious how you have
if if it all thought about rights of
Passage for your own kids or how you
might suggest parents think about rights
of Passage
primarily for for males but it could
also apply to females you know I had two
girls and you know when they each got
their periods they came to me not to
their mother
why why is that do you think
you'd have to ask them but I mean I had
that kind of relationship with them I
mean what we've done obviously with our
daughters we've been able to take them
all around the world you know
and also while they grew up we own a
fishing lodge a very modest fishing
lodge but very remote seven hours from
the nearest town three days Drive North
of Vancouver in taltan country and so
while they grew up and I was traveling a
great deal for the National Geographic
the the two or three months we would
spend there every summer became kind of
the well the family drank from for the
rest of the year and for those months
they hung out with tall tan kids all the
time and so they they have this
unbelievable kind of sense of the world
you know my daughter speaks Arabic one
of them you know another I remember
our house in Washington in particular
was kind of a Grand Central Station
everybody was free to crash there and
you never knew who was going to turn up
but
I just had a friend call me who reminded
me of the day he woke up there and found
four Mongolians drinking vodka at six
a.m in the kitchen and one time we had
Nilda kalana but his great friend of
mine a weaver from really a National
Treasure from Cusco staying in one guest
room and I'd forgotten to tell my
daughters that a friend of mine from
Mali ESO Muhammad a torg massive guy was
there for the folklike festival so
they didn't know he was staying there
and he comes up from the basement guest
room in full ritual regalia like looking
like Lawrence of Arabia this guy this
massive guy much bigger than me he comes
into the kitchen spreads his arms across
the kitchen my girls were eating rice
krispies at the table and he just says
miso phones and they just look up at
this incredible African guy could you
translate that please yeah my children
I'm here
they just looked up at him and they said
hello sir how are you you must be a
friend of my father's can we get you
some breakfast please I mean other than
on plus you know so it's you know those
the kind of initiation rights I think
for
you know for boys in in the American
context and culture it really is great
to find ways for them to go away and do
physical labor you know this is why I
think there should be youth Conservation
Corps in every state and National Park
you know there's nothing better than for
a 15 year old boy with all those
hormonal spasms and all that pimply face
to just be forced to cut firewood all
day yeah these kind of opportunities
aren't trivial they create the character
of our young there's no reason
whatsoever that our government in the
United States shouldn't be able to
mobilize resources that would make
available to every Young American boy
and girl the opportunity to travel
within America to know another face of
America another section of the country
you know Californians to Iowa Kansas to
Miami and so on and give them work to
help make us a better country you know
whether it's picking up plastic or
caring for the elderly whatever it is
again giving young people a sense that
they're not the center of the universe
you know that they that they live to
help others that we do exist as a
community
that you have to be humble and just
because you believe it doesn't mean it's
true and that the democratization of
opinion doesn't mean that your opinion
counts as much as an elder who has lived
through life that you can't even imagine
you know there are ways to make this
possible but physical activity is the
key I think particularly for men which
is why
say what you will about the military
you know it is done more good for more
young men in its history
not that obviously we would not
criticize some of the engagements but
you know what I'm saying as an
institution of the nation
that stands for the nation you know
young people have to learn that there's
something bigger than themselves that
they need to be loyal to and that's not
necessarily a country it's a concept
it's the idea of community it's
something we really noticed him in
Canada
which is no perfect place but one of the
things that is so different in Canada is
that there is really a sense of
community we really are a social
democracy and it creates for a different
way of life I mean one thing I I don't
want to belabor this but you know in
America Universal Health Care is seen as
socialist medicine and health care in
general is seen as a uniquely medical
issue right and that is to miss the
point completely Universal Health Care
which we have in Canada has nothing to
do with medicine it has everything to do
with social solidarity it has everything
to do with every Canadian knowing that
they belong and knowing that if their
kid gets sick they will get exactly and
I tell you it is exactly the same care
as any other Canadian including the
Prime Minister yes I sometimes have to
wait for medical service in Canada but
everyone does but no one is Left Behind
and that is one of the reasons that we
have a less highly charged
Society you know why we seem to get
along better
hmm
I certainly agree with that and I also
agree with the physical
labor component and the importance of it
for boys and young men and men overall
but I think especially in that hormonal
tidal wave period let's just call it
from whatever it might be you know 13 to
18 and in addition to the
Transcendence of the self to a larger
cause say in a military context it
strikes me that both the military and
the physical exertion of say having to
chop wood all day
serve a similar
purpose in that of shared privation
which is a term you hear in a military
context and that is a group of boys
going through some form of suffering
together and it does seem to activate
something in the male psyche that is
hard to access otherwise one of my most
memorable experiences when I was 20 I
was just come back from the Seattle
Nevada with the Momos and Tim was going
back to Harvard to get his degree and I
had a month off until he was going to
return and I ran into this crazy
Englishman who had walked from the tip
of South America and he was walking to
Alaska and he was sending these
dispatches to his newspaper the London
Sunday Observer and I'm not sure what he
wrote Because in 18 months of walking he
hadn't learned a word of Spanish
but but anyway he hired me to guide him
through the notary and GAP the only
stretch of this tree very dangerous that
had no Road and he didn't care that I
knew nothing about the area that was
great because he kind of cultivated
Misadventures as fodder for his his
books and in the course of that Journey
we became it was incredible during the
rainy season walking in swamps up to the
neck for days at a time at one point we
got lost in the in the jungle with three
kuna Indians for 12 days with no food
you know I was down 146 pounds at one
point Sebastian was down to 120 we had
to carry the other Indian lad and at one
point when we were at the Wit's End I
just said we gotta go and I took the gun
and I walked up this trail and I ran
right into a black jaguar and you know
if you ever run into a Jaguar they've
got these yellow eyes they don't look at
you they look through you they you feel
like you've been x-rayed and I just
looked at that incredibly beautiful
creature and then it leapt off the road
and I thought we had two weeks to walk
to get to rescue but we found our way to
the end of the road that day
and it was just like a miracle and
at the end of this extraordinary
misadventure I got off the plane in
Panama City
I'd flown out in this cramped Cessna the
girl beside me had puked on me her
mother turned around to console the
daughter she puked on me I only had the
rotten clothes in my back three dollars
is my name and one bottle of beer this
engineer had given me I arrived in
Panama City with nothing more than that
and no plans whatsoever but I had never
felt more alive I had been on my own
hero's journey and I had survived and
and and that you know would be etched
into my character you know if I could do
that I could do anything
um
this may seem well it's not random
because you prompted it in a way so
black jaguars are not common as far as I
know what did the kuna Indians make of
that black jaguar they didn't see it I
was way ahead of them I was just
wondering even if you told them if the
if if that carried any special
significance oh they would see that as
oh for sure I mean they're nothing
nothing is accidental when it comes to
to that you know when you're with
people's like the buddhasana the makuna
you know they their most profound
cultural Insight one might say is their
conviction that plants and animals are
just people in another dimension of
reality so if you even you know their
hunting myths become kind of a Land
Management plan dictating how people can
live in the forest so that the shaman is
he's not just a priest or a physician
he's kind of like a nuclear engineer who
goes to the heart of the reactor to
reprogram the world so you know there's
there's a constant dialogue between
human beings and the natural world so no
event has a life of its own
I do want to at some point and I'm
saying this to remind myself and maybe
remind you to remind me about getting
better at writing and teaching yourself
to write on multiple levels we'll get to
that but since you brought up
the people
in other dimensions effectively
manifesting as as plants and animals I'd
like to discuss
it doesn't have to be brief we have as
much time as we want but
the different origin stories
of this Brew called Ayahuasca which
exists in many different iterations used
by many many different tribal groups and
cultures at this point and churches also
syncretic religions at this point but
I'm wondering how you would explain the
development of this particular
combination of of plants and the reason
I ask is that I've heard many different
explanations for this so one is just
trial and error over a very long period
of time
another on the opposite end of the
spectrum would be
the plants told us that way
and I'm wondering how you would
explain the the arrival at this
combination of say Vine and DMT
containing a plant well first of all you
know one thing I mentioned about
Ayahuasca or Yahoo is that the the idea
we often have of it as we you know go
down to uh
the healers of the shapibo you know as
if it's sort of a quest for personal
Liberation personal well-being that's
always been there in the traditional use
of hallucinogens in South America you
know the the traditional syncretic Cult
of the cactus of the Four Winds and the
coronderos who use San Pedro cactus on
the coast and certainly the
popularization of Ayahuasca began with
the Yahoo letters between William
Burroughs right and Alan Ginsburg and it
was Burrows who turned up in Bogota goes
to the herbarium meets who he calls doc
Schindler who is schulte's and schulte's
sends them off and eventually gets gets
him
Ayahuasca in mccoa and on that road
between sibandoi and Moko in the upper
bhutamayo when I was there in the 1970s
there were already
you know individual healers sort of
working with the Gringo trade but also
working with individual campesinos
and of course in all of these healing
practices
the ideas that the imbalance of the
individual is treated through the
medicine and whether the imbalance is
caused by
bad health
poor finances personal problems whatever
it's a balance the source that one gets
to but I mentioned that only to stress
that it is completely a different
situation when you get into the heart of
the Northwest Amazon where presumably
these plants were were originated these
preparations so for example one of the
powerful
themes that is somewhat like what the
kogi do this idea that you know that
human beings aren't the problem we're
the solution because only through the
human imagination can The Wonder of the
natural world become manifest that that
we are the ones who have to maintain the
energetic flows of the universe we have
this proactive role to play well in the
Northwest Amazon it's very much that way
I mean the the main origin myth that in
one way or another is shared by multiple
cultures speaks of a great journey from
the East up The Milk River in sacred
canoes
dragged by anaconda and in the canoes
are all the hierarchy the the Chiefs
wisdom keeper the dancers the Warriors
the slaves and also the three vital
plants Koka yahi and tobacco and these
are brought up the Milk River and
originally they were brought up by the
Iowa the four Thunders these
mythological culture Heroes and they
encountered a world of total devastation
and they turned that world upside down
and brought order to it by destroying
the negative forces so this idea that
humans are responsible for the
equilibrium and then the Iowa's went up
and became the stars and then the great
mother romikumu brought the people up
and the people settled each River and
because each River was settled by a
unique canoe each language group are
related to each other you can't marry
within your language so one of the
extraordinary things in North with
Amazon is it is a linguistic exogamy
when you marry you must marry someone
who speaks a different language
but the use of Ayahuasca is not
individualistic it's Collective at these
great ceremonies that go on for two and
three days where the individuals the men
all the people are there but only men
take
they go through two different kinds of
ritual
paraphernalia feather work
a day by night and they literally by
taking Ayahuasca don't become symbols of
the ancestors they become the ancestors
and they fly away to all the sacred
sites
to pay homage to
the natural world to maintain the
harmonic balance so the critical thing
here is that the use of the plant
preparation has nothing to do with any
individual's well-being but rather
becomes a prayer a ceremony for the
collective well-being and survival of
the culture and it becomes a mediator to
the Divine and so the kinds of things
you see in the kind of Gringo
Ayahuasca business around aquitos
is not traditional in that sense now as
to how this knowledge was discovered I
mean there are a couple possibilities
first of all there is a species of
maltigation's Vine diplateris Cabrera
which looks very much like Yahoo and
does have DMT in it so maybe they saw
that then they saw the opposite leaves
they saw the
psychotria coffee plant opposite leaves
clearly there's experimentation going on
but it's not just with Ayahuasca take
something like karari the remarkable
thing about karari it's a muscle
relaxant but to affect the muscles it
has to get into the blood you can drink
as much karory as you want and if you
don't have some kind of wound in your
stomach you'll be fine but again how do
you how do you rationally explain that
process of elaboration you know and and
you mentioned trial and error well I
think statistically that is just exposed
as a meaningless euphemism now I
mentioned that story about Schultz is
saying you know the siona Sequoia and
the 17 varieties sing to you in a
different key well whatever that really
means when the people say the plants
teach us I'm quite prepared at this
point in my life to take them at their
word and the reason I say that is that
that these men largely men also women
but but in terms of Ayahuasca these
aren't
sort of random characters these are true
natural philosophers who understand that
Flora in ways that few scientists could
ever aspire to do they have spent their
lives in wisdom Traditions lineages that
have been taking all of this common
genius that I keep talking about we all
share as human beings and applying it to
that challenge I mean for example I mean
just jumping away for a second you know
when you go to Australia you realize
that the entire purpose of life is not
to change the world but to do the
rituals to keep the world just as it was
well imagine how much would be learned
if the people of New York City had spent
all of their existence putting all of
their energy and capacity into
understanding the biological
relationships of Central Park I mean
it'd be incredible right so so when we
say the plants teach us I'm not sure
what that means I don't quite know how
how it become operative but I do know
and I've had this experience myself
taking any number of psychoactive
substances that you have insights that
become
almost challenging to believe in the
wake of your experience yeah I never
understood the glory of photosynthesis I
never appreciated the miracle of this
verse of life this idea that you know
water can come together with carbon
dioxide and create the air that we
breathe and the food that we eat I mean
that's the poetic verse every child
should have to memorize and no
politician should ever be able to run
for office if they can't recite the
formula of photosynthesis and but the
point is I remember I took Kim and I
discovered a new species of San Pedro
cactus in 1974 in Bolivia and we took a
big walk of it on the Eastern side of
the Andes and knowing that it was safe
and you know Tim I mean schulte's used
to say Tim and I ate our way through
South America if anything back then had
a chance to get us High we would take it
it was I mean we're crazy we're kids but
anyway we took this I took as Tim and I
made ready to say goodbye to each other
after over a year and a half traveling
together we took this extraordinary
parents would call heroic dose of this
new species we had found and we were up
for 48 hours and at one point we just
left the ground and we were like flying
over the surface of the Earth and I
looked down and I saw the Nazca Lines
you know and I became convinced that
that's how that explained how these guys
conceived those Monumental structures
but but at that same experience I saw
Tim fly up like Icarus to the Sun and
disappear and I knew right then he was
going to die and he would be dead in in
short order in fact from AIDS
that's incredible and for people who
don't have the context the Nazca Lines
which I've seen from the error are
something to behold so you see these
these huge
pictures on the ground anthropomorphic
figures that from the ground you can
never make out but from 10 000 feet you
see these perfectly etched forms of
spiders and you know monkeys monkeys and
and also someone they refer to as E.T
because it looks bizarrely like our
modern day depictions of of aliens so go
figure that one out question for you
about the historic use of Ayahuasca to
what extent was Ayahuasca or Yahoo
predominantly used for say hunting or
divination purposes versus healing
purposes
obviously it depends on the setting the
culture the moment in time
certainly
all of these entheogens are used in the
course of healing I mean the the essence
of the shamanic art of healing is the
idea that disease is not caused by
pathogens but by an imbalance that has
to be addressed and to do so the shaman
must invoke some technique of ecstasy to
soar away on the wings of Trance to get
into these distant metaphysical Realms
where he or she can do their work of
medical magical mystical rescues so so
Ayahuasca in that sense
has always I think been associated with
Healing Arts but again in in the context
of periodic rituals and ceremonies as I
mentioned like the with the batasana
that we filmed actually
the celebration of cassava woman a kind
of fertility ritual there it's a journey
of the community you know the journey
the community comes together in ritual I
mean this idea of communities coming
together in ritual doesn't have to
involve
these sacred plants I mean in the Andes
for example in the community of
chinchera once each year outside of
Cusco the fastest young boy is given the
honor of becoming a woman and he puts on
the clothing of a sister and he leads
all able-bodied men on a run but it's
not your ordinary run you start off at
11 500 feet Run 2 000 feet down to the
base of the Sacred mountain and then you
run to 16 000 feet and then you drop
down to the sacred Valley and cross two
more soaring Indian ridges and you're
running the boundaries of the community
land but the wonderful metaphors that
you go into the mountain as an
individual but you sacrifice which means
in Latin to make sacred from Pure
exhaustion you merge into a single
community that once again has expressed
both its ownership but also its
obligations to then I I did that race
when I was 48 years old
the only Outsider ever to do it I
trained six months with an
African-American boxer
in DC in a gym and I only got through
the day by chewing more coca leaves than
anyone in the 5 000 year history of the
plan yeah that's it does help I I will
say that of every remedy that was
offered to me that I certainly tested
when I was suffering from altitude
sickness in South America the only thing
that fixed it and fixed it very quickly
was coca leaf tea it was remarkable it's
a miracle well I mean coca without
diverting ourselves to Ayahuasca prayers
but I mean the thing about Coca Tim you
know it's not just that coke is not
cocaine it's not just that you know it's
been misunderstood or whatever the real
tragedy is that Humanity as a whole has
been robbed of the benefits of this
incredible plant you know if you go back
to the 19th century when Physicians were
studying coca heralding its virtues in a
non-judgmental context with open access
to the leaves time and again they would
be
fuddled by its activity they called it
the stimulant that wasn't a stimulant in
other words you you would chew the
leaves and you felt nothing except the
consequences of having done so you
suddenly felt a slight elevation of mood
and the ability to concentrate and focus
perhaps and drop an appetite but you had
no sense of the kind of you know
charge you get when even you drink a
strong cup of coffee and this of course
is what makes the plant so perfect for
our Modern Age I mean who wouldn't like
to have access to a substance that
gently elevated their move that was
utterly benign it had five thousand
years of safe use that was a sacred
plant that allowed you to focus on your
damn laptop without getting distracted
to email that allowed you to overcome
that slight inertia that keeps you from
writing that first sentence of your
report and then you suddenly discovered
at the end of the day you've been doing
this so productively for eight hours and
you just go home and you go to sleep or
you have your meal or whatever with no
side effects whatsoever and you can do
it again the next day and the next day
the next day and before you know it you
see that your productivity your
well-being your health
has soared you know Tim people always
say to me you know how on Earth have you
written 23 books and I just wink
oh well I'd love to open a bottle of
wine and talk about that wig sometime
certainly I would like to do some more
writing myself let me come back to
Ayahuasca just for a moment because you
mentioned the the trinity in many of
these cultures of Koka yake and tobacco
and I'm fascinated by tobacco that's a
longer story for maybe another time but
I have read I think his name is I'm
mispronouncing this but Johannes Wilbert
and his book on it was wonderful oh good
for you amazing book He's a beautiful
man he just died yeah yeah he's very sad
he was another one of my great mentors
oh no kidding all right so oh yeah
tobacco is a whole separate chapter that
I'd love to talk about for hours but
another Trinity I've seen mentioned is
you know cassava Ayahuasca and then Palm
for different for different reasons
I have read a number of papers or at
least one paper I should say that in the
hunting context also mentioned use of
Ayahuasca or dosing of hunting dogs with
Ayahuasca and I'm wondering if that can
be explained simply by hyper dilation of
the pupils maybe better hunting at night
something along those lines
or if there's another explanation that
the people doing it would offer these
things don't necessarily have a
practical utility you know because
someone feeds their dog either datura or
Ayahuasca
doesn't imply that the dog therefore
must get some attribute from that dose I
mean sure it could easily be a kind of a
magical idea you know or you know a
metaphysical idea a Transcendent idea
but there is that you know there isn't
that separation from human beings and
animals in that in that sense
a lot of that goes on in the Amazon I
mean you mentioned Yuka I mean one of
the fascinating things is that there are
many female anthropologists today but in
the early years it was obviously
dominated by men and in the Northwest
Amazon in particular
there's a very clear division of labor I
would never say that women are
subordinate on the contrary but there's
a very clear division of labor and for
example the gardens the chocolates are
very much the domain of the women I once
made a mistake in a long house
sane in front of all the men to all the
women boy I'd love you to take me to the
garden and show me your cultivated
plants and everybody laughed their heads
off because the gardens are also where
you go to make love so I'd essentially
proposition every woman in the maloka
you know and but it does suggest that
the realm of the woman is not readily
accessible to men I mean I've often had
you know people say to me you know all
your books it seems to be a man's world
well it's a man's world in the sense
that I'm a man but that doesn't mean
that I'm not respectful of the woman's
fear and one of the exciting studies
that was done with the batasana
by two great ethnographers Stephen Hugh
Jones and his wife Christine Hugh Jones
while Stephen was looking at the Yuri
Pari cult in Ayahuasca and his book was
published as a palm in the Pleiades
Christine was hanging for all those
years with the women and her book from
The Milk River shows that the
preparation of bitter manioc is wrapped
in as much cosmology as much
significance as Ayahuasca I mean if you
think about in the Northwest Amazon the
main food is cassava and cassava is made
from bitter Maniac or Tapioca And it's
an incredibly elaborate process that the
women have to do every day transforming
a poisonous
root crop into the daily food of their
children and it's not surprising that
the the equipment and the the process is
absolutely celebrated in mythological
terms and that's was Christine's great
contribution of that book
um
so I will segue to the question on
writing because I selfishly also want to
know the answer but but I would like to
spend a little bit more time
on
this sphere of psychedelics
with your experience of traveling over
experientially
after taking this new species of the San
Pedro cactus and then seeing your friend
flying into the Sun and having this
realization
how do you explain these phenomena those
types of experiences which seem to
happen with some degree of regularity
and shared Visions at least purportedly
shared Visions with Ayahuasca and things
at this time well you know I mean I
think this is why you know human beings
in all places through all time have been
fascinated by these enthusians because
they really do reveal Realms of ethereal
wonder and as you well know in such a
way that you almost are left feeling
that the world lovely as it is that we
dwell in in our ordinary Consciousness
is almost like a crude facts simile of a
realm that is beyond our imaginings at
the other side of Consciousness if you
want and I think that as I've always
said you know I mentioned earlier these
sort of great social Transformations
that can leave us
I think hopeful
but when we look at the ingredients in
the recipe that allowed for those social
changes
there's one ingredient that we tend to
expunge from the record which is the
fact that millions of us in that era the
60s and 70s
took psychedelics
and you know I don't think I would think
the way I think I don't think I would
write the way I write I don't think I
would understand cultural relativism as
I do I don't think I would be drawn to
Nature as I am I don't think I'd treat
women the way I do understand
gay men and women be as tolerant and
open as I've obviously am and have
always been if I hadn't taken
psychedelics I mean I always make this
joke that her parents said don't take
these things you'll never come back the
same and they poor parents didn't
understand that was the entire point of
the exercise we didn't have to come back
the same we wanted to come back
transformed I mean I think this was the
the the key to my generation you know we
all suffered from baudelaire's malady a
horror of home you know we we grew up in
a world that we found to be problematic
or at least I did in terms of our
treatment of the environment the way we
treated women or the way we treated
people of color the way that gay men and
women were treated you know
and I went out looking for a more
authentic life in a different world and
so there was almost no separation
between my desire to know other cultures
and other places
and knowing other Realms of
Consciousness just went hand in hand
with that right and I think in a way
looking back this sort of became the
multi the multiple elements of what was
in effect my hero's journey you know I
set off with no plans except to be away
for at least a year I had enough money
to stay you know with a budget of three
dollars a day I my only promise was that
I was not going to come back to the
United States until Richard Nixon was no
longer president and I waited them out
and I I was gone 15 months but looking
back on those months
it was an absolute initiation
you know I came back a different person
which is of course what one wants to do
when one travels
you have said that psychedelics were
useful to you when you were young but
later on more perhaps disorienting and
less helpful do you still
feel that way if that's an accurate
statement
ever since Leary and Albert and Andy
Weil began sharing this concept of set
and setting we've known that these
substances kind of invoke and they
create a they're completely neutral they
had kind of a template upon which
beliefs expectations ones one set and
the setting of The Experience can can
play roles and I personally found and I
I really believe in the kind of The
Vedic notion of the stages of life you
know you're you're a child you're a
young man you become a householder and
then you are free to wander as a sadhu
as you approach the end of your life and
I think one wants to try to be in sync
with those stages if you will
and when I was a young kid trying in
high school to deconstruct the world
around me I love to smoke pot because we
would just say you know how it was
you're 1516 just laughing at the world
and all the idioces around you you know
and similarly you know psychedelics kind
of opened my mind I mean these are
powerful forces let's just remember that
because of psychedelics the Beatles went
from she loves you to Tomorrow Never
Knows in two years think about that yeah
and then when I found Tim is to be
honest with you I lived such a crazy
life I mean I didn't have a home I own
nothing but artifacts and books I I was
on the go constantly you know what I
owned was in storage I was you know the
amount of travel it was all exciting but
you know at the time it was
also very kind of confusing you know I
was very ambitious to know what my
destiny would be I knew I didn't really
want to be an academic I loved botany
but I wasn't going to be a botanist and
so on and and jumping ahead it was when
I wrote The Serpent of the rainbow that
things clicked I said oh that's what I
am I can write
but you know there was a very
powerful year for me where I was living
in France
after I'd finished the serp in the
rainbow but before it had come out and I
was writing my PhD in living the French
girlfriend in a small village of 26
people in Provence and the Alps the low
Alps and I got a phone call in the night
that my father had died and I
immediately came home to Canada
and that year I can't remember the order
that this happened but I had a letter
waiting for me from Gail and in coming
home from France I walked out of a
relationship of five years with this
older French woman got home there was a
letter waiting from Gail who is now my
wife of 35 years
within a year my father had died I
graduated from Harvard after 18 years of
it being my home
I had met Gail she was pregnant with the
first child
my book had come out and I've made a
fortune I bought a house with cash
and I was suddenly a father and a
husband and living in British Columbia
in a home and writing a book about
schulte's having lost my father earlier
in the year I mean all of that
also that year the Hollywood movie came
out based on the book it was like the
eating my world turned over and I I
found myself once I became a father
you know a whole different set of
priorities now I had successfully built
a world
I revered that world I lived by that
world and I didn't really at that
critical time when I was
a new husband a new father
getting my career underway establishing
a reputation as a speaker you know
living in this little house on a hill
writing this biography of schulte's that
I had no idea whether it would be
successful and become almost the cult
book that it is the point is that at
that time it was not the time to be
blowing open my mind right contrary
right right it was a time to consolidate
to take all I had learned all my
Vagabond dreams and pulled them together
as as I kind of wove the fabric of my
own
individual life and and since then you
know I've taken Ayahuasca largely to
sort of remember what it was like when I
was riding One River and I've taken a
few I think I could easily find myself
experimenting once again
particularly as I get older and perhaps
are approaching death that's one of the
things that I think that these
psychedelics are incredibly useful not
to eliminate fear of death but to help
make it seem natural normal and which it
is and I'm not here judging I mean I
think if you look back
Leary for example or John Lennon for
that matter
I would argue took way too much LSD
where's George Harrison and ramdas
famously as they wrote got the message
and hung up in other words I'm not sure
how many times you need
to take these substances to sort of
learn what you're going to learn from
them now that that's me I mean other
people find these to be part of an
ongoing journey and engagement one of
the things I do find interesting is how
the Gestalt on Ayahuasca has changed if
you had asked me Tim I first took
Ayahuasca in 1974 and if you had asked
me then which of all the plants that I
was becoming familiar with would be the
one that you know 45 years later would
be in every hallway of America I would
never have said Ayahuasca I mean you
know as Tim used to say Ayahuasca is
about many things Pleasant isn't one of
them and when you talk to the indigenous
people it's fascinating you know they
they use language like
you're the warrior confronting the
you know those you know you're you're
nursing at the breast of Jaguar mother
when she rips you from her tit and
flings you into a pit of poisonous
vipers I mean I I once lived with Randy
Borman we took Ayahuasca with the kofan
and we had a very interesting
kind of spontaneous session after
the experience and I was asking you know
I said to these men I'd been through the
Journey with I said you know you know I
got to tell you this stuff scares the
hell out of me and they all looked at me
said of course it does that's what it's
supposed to do you know and so what I
find interesting is that you know people
of of your generation and younger are
all sort of reporting how kind of
transcendent and Blissful and wonderful
Ayahuasca was I mean the last time I
took it just to try to remember what it
was like to write about it I remember
sort of clinging to my wife for about 24
hours
yeah but anyway I mean this is all in
the realm of set and setting I I do find
that I prefer something like San Pedro
cactus for the kind of visceral
connection to the natural world
yeah I feel like not that dissimilar
from your
description or the impetus behind
the wayfinders that not polemics not
politics but storytelling is what you
could use to drive a change in culture I
think that ayahuasca
maybe counterintuitively because of the
just awful experiences that some people
many people will have or challenging
let's just say
has all the ingredients for great
storytelling you have a group setting
you have in most cases at least in the
United States and imported exotic Shaman
who is running the show you have shared
privation in the form of vomiting and
God knows what else
and you have just the perfect cocktail
for Word of Mouth in so many ways and I
think for that reason
it has traveled and become so sexy in a
sense unlike say mushrooms that in the
United States these philosophy mushrooms
are taken in a very recreational setting
which would be very dissimilar from say
the mazatek traditional use but that
never made the Hop it never crossed the
border I always wonder if in the morning
after taking Ayahuasca I always just
feel happy to be alive and I'm sometimes
with these young people whether it's
just that they're seeing they're so
happy to have gotten through it you know
but anyway it's it's a phenomenon
yeah I think there's also a
selection bias for the highlight reels
it's much like if you're part of a
religion meaning I'm using religion in
quotation marks
that is dietary focused right and if
your hair starts falling up because
you're following some weird diet you
don't want to confess that to the group
because you'll be ostracized so you just
don't talk about how oh I felt
destabilized for two weeks but you do
tell them like oh I had this inside
about my dad and things are so much
better now anyway I'll put that aside
let's talk about writing I really enjoy
your writing it is
poetic it has a
a very nuanced
play of words and wordsmithing and I've
in the course of doing research for this
conversation came across you mentioning
on on several occasions that you were
forced to teach yourself to write well
and I'm most curious
and not necessarily why that was the
case but what the process looked like
how did you teach yourself to write well
well that's good I mean a lot of
aspiring writers out there you know I
mean I wasn't aware of myself having
been anything like a writer and say high
school I mean I I later looked back and
was surprised to learn that I won the
English prize you know in the history
prize and I did have a tremendous
foundation in English grammar you know I
I went to a a private school in Montreal
in grade seven where we had to memorize
like the 120 sentence errors in English
grammar and literally we got whacked if
we didn't know them so you know that may
sound silly but but no grammar is the
architecture of writing I mean if you
don't understand basic grammar you can
never be a writer and I have a
just an incredible
intuitive understanding of the grammar
of the English language because of that
experience when I was young and what
happened you know and I always kept
journals when I was on the road and I
certainly
was deeply impressed and I had mentors
like the poet Gary Snyder I never went
anywhere without one of Gary's volumes
of poems in my backpack Peter matthewson
a number of writers that I really
admired I was always drawn to the genre
of travel books because that's sort of
what I was doing who I was but what
actually happened with
with the case of the The Serpent of the
rainbow is as I said earlier in the
podcast
you know the zombie research was funded
by Dr Klein they set up a dummy
foundation called the international
psychiatric Research Foundation and
literally at the beginning if I needed
five thousand ten thousand dollars by
Wednesday I just had to call New York by
Monday night and I never knew who was
the benefactor but it turned out to be a
wonderful man David Merrick the Broadway
producer who at that time had just had a
huge success with on Broadway with 42nd
street and David had also done obviously
a number of feature films and he must
have been hearing from Dr Klein about my
Misadventures and he saw a film from the
very start in this and then again as I
mentioned earlier in an unbelievable 24
hours Dr Klein died during routine heart
surgery and Mr Merrick had a
debilitating stroke so I literally went
overnight from being flushed with
support to having none and I did apply
to all the standard research sources you
know various grants foundations but they
all take months and months to let you
know whether you're going to get the
money or not and I I had guided that
British journalist through the Darien
Gap his name was Sebastian snow and he
had written a really kind of dreadful
book about his journey called the
rucksacked man and he actually lifted
whole passages out of my Diaries into
his book which actually was a fair
exchange because it was the first time I
saw my writing in print albeit lifted
from my journals and he actually I was
able to give him something we're saying
because I spoke Spanish was hanging with
the Indians all the time he knew nothing
about where he was he said if he spoke
to queen's English loud enough they'd
understand he he was just as complete
eccentric guy he went mad actually on
that in Costa Rica but that's a whole
nother story but I thought well my God
if he he could write a book I can write
a book so that was an idea he generously
gave me the address of his literary
agent in London I walked off the street
and said I've got a couple of ideas and
this sort of Englishman looked down his
nose as they often do to Canadians you
know well there might be something in
that zombie thing and before I I knew it
you know I dictated the story into a
typewriter what happened to me how to
transcribe a type bite the late EO
Wilson secretary and I had this big sort
of 150 page thing and I gave it in as a
book proposal got a contract for what
then was an enormous amount of money for
me thirty five thousand dollars spending
on some fun in Paris with a girlfriend
and then used the rest of it to finish
the research and then I had to actually
write a book and I wrote two chapters in
Haiti I had malaria and hepatitis at the
same time and I was really sick and I
wrote two chapters that I thought was
the best thing since the Bible and I
sent it to the editor and he sort of
sent it back to me and said try again
and so then I then I left the University
and a very dear friend of mine sort of
plucked me out of Haiti and brought me
to her beautiful Farm in Virginia to
both get well but also to write the book
and I stayed there
working in a slave cabin for seven
months and I you know I had a great
story to tell I had lived this story I
just had to find the way to tell it so
what I did and no one gave me this idea
and I certainly had never taken a
creative writing course I mean most
creative writing courses are taught by
people who are teaching creative writing
courses because they can't write
creatively and otherwise they'd be not
doing that they'd be writing books but
that may be a little harsh but all of us
lots of times have to get academic jobs
don't get me wrong but what I did is I
just took all my favorite books
Hemingway for example for dialogue no
one's better Isaac Dennison for
landscape Lawrence Darrell in the
Alexandria Quartet how do you how do you
evoke the exoticism of places surreal is
Haiti well how about Alexandria the
1940s you know Carpentier for mystical
thing and this pile by my typewriter you
know kept changing and so on but it was
always there and I never obviously
copied or plagiarized but as I was
trying to tell my story and I was stuck
on how to do it like what language to
use I would just pick up any book
randomly and read for a while and it was
just weird almost like by osmosis I
would and I was often writing at night I
had lots of Coca and I was kind of in
this kind of creative space and again
you know
one thing that I think a lesson of all
that is in the end I wrote that book in
seven months and it was edited in the
single day and it came out and it sold
500 000 copies hold on hold on hold on
you say edit it in a single day oh yeah
almost no editing whatsoever no okay all
right got it got it got it what I mean
by that is there's lots of different
ways of writing you know some people
like to sort of spit out a first draft
as they say or you know or just puke it
onto the page well I've just never
understood how you could make something
beautiful of puke
so I to my detriment perhaps I'm a much
more laborious writer and I've never
done a second draft
of a book I do that in a way as I'm
going through you know as I write a
paragraph you know I'm paying attention
I think writing's analogous to sculpture
you know you're you got to pay attention
like Barbara tuckman the great historian
had a little note above her typewriter
will they turn the page you know and and
you have to create rhythms in every line
you have to end every paragraph with
something that's going to make the
reader one and it becomes unconscious
right but but at the same time you're
paying attention to the Cadence of every
word at least I am and that's when you
talk about lyricism and that was a skill
I had to learn in the early days you
know it was very funny my wife wouldn't
bother to edit or look at anything I
write anymore we've been married too
long but in the early days she was
wonderful at not editing per se she
never added any words or deleted
anything but she had a little stamp that
we called the puke meter and if I had
passage where I you know went beyond
lyricism the purple prose she just stamp
it you know like little faces from
throwing up and that was really kind of
wonderful because she was a great reader
and you learned
you can always go out on the lyrical
Edge if you will because you can always
pull it back but you can't
bring Spirit to dry prose you know and
it's interesting I mean like everything
else you get better and better the more
you do it now I write
bizarrely effortlessly I mean no one
writes effortlessly I mean we said
anyway says they write easily is either
a bad writer or a liar
also I've never mistook activity for
results because I've been self-employed
most of my life and I've never indulged
writer's block can you imagine if a
plumber came to your home looked at you
and suddenly
patted their brow and said just can't do
it today I've got plumber's block you'd
call them the police right no writing's
a craft you get up in the morning and
you do it but one of the things that
really was amazing to me a real turning
point in my life having been raised in
that kind of simple middle class
world where creativity happens to
someone else you know the Beatles are
creative Leonard Bernstein is creative
whatever when I finally understood that
creativity is not the motivation of
action it's a consequence of action if
you don't do you can't create so you
know that insight and acting on the
Insight changed my life I never sat
around to wait for permission to write
about any subject you know people will
say oh I can't write about World War one
because I'm a botanist no you you apply
the same research skills that you use to
write about the Haitian zombie to
understanding the essence of British
culture in Edwardian England you know
and in the same token you can't be a
photographer if you don't take pictures
you know the way you become a better
photographer is to take more and more
images and to study the work of the
Masters that's what I always would say
A2
a young person you know if you want to
write non-fiction
find the non-fiction that you think is
the best going and pay attention don't
just read it study it it's the same
thing with music listen to any of these
great characters from Jimmy Page to the
Beloved and late Jeff Beck it's terrible
he passed away
they always talk about how they mind the
work of every other blues player before
them you know practice practice I mean
Jerry Garcia never had a guitar out of
his hands nor did Hendricks you know so
you just have to do it it's that classic
idea you know do what needs to be done
and only then ask whether it was
permissible or possible you know one of
the things that I've found him about
life is that at every single stage of
life there's someone telling you you
shouldn't do something
and nobody wants you to change you know
in my case it was like
you're from Canada what's wrong with the
university why do you have to go to
Harvard wait a minute you're supposed to
be a lawyer what's this anthropology
thing wait a minute you didn't answer
but what's this botany thing we just
came back from the Amazon what's this
Voodoo thing wait a minute how can you
go work on a logging you can't your
father just spent half his money sending
you to this fancy School wait have you
been in the logging Camp why should you
be a park ranger you know wait a minute
it's always like that and you just can't
look behind you I remember our mutual
friend Mark Plotkin once told me you
know in the early days you know the
problem with climbing up the flagpole is
that there's always somebody looking up
your butt
by the way That's a classic Mark kind of
line that is a classic Mark line that is
a very classic Mark like
well I I must say wade this is an
extremely enjoyable conversation for you
I'm taking a lot of notes there are many
other questions that I would love to ask
but I think I'll make it not so much
dealer's choice but guest choice so let
me let me offer three options for sort
of wrapping up and then I would love to
have you pick so the first option which
is actually a question that Mark
suggested although I would also love to
know the answer that is why has Harvard
not maintained their role as a leader in
ethnobotany so that's option one option
two is you attended and spoke at Dennis
McKenna's spd55 conference and I've had
Dennis on the on the podcast as well
what can you tell us about the current
and future use of infusions by Western
societies and then the last option which
just came to mind because
Kurt Vonnegut I think
separates sort of the
the brain vomit first draft and then
refine folks as swoopers and then I
think folks who operate more like
yourself as plotters I want to say and I
tend to write more similar to how you
write not to compare my writing to yours
but I tend to rework and rework and
rework but that only works for me if I
have a very reliable outline so I was
going to ask you about your outlining
process when writing I'd much rather
talk about writing actually if we do the
third one let's do it I think all
writers discover their own kind of
methods I mean by definition and what I
do
and the strength of my books and the way
that some people might even call them
too dense is that they're incredibly
deeply researched you know the book we
haven't really talked about into the
silence which actually won the prize for
the top book in the English language
which was then called the Samuel Johnson
prize that took 12 years and
in that process I bought 600 books
with either myself or my research
assistant we visited 57 archives you
know multiple Journeys to Tibet I had
the spiritual autobiography the nemtar
of zafarinpochet translated
from wrong book translated by monks in
Kathmandu I spent weeks myself in the
monastery established by his spiritual
Heir just to know what wrong book would
have looked like in 1921 and so on so
just insane amounts of of research and
and then what I do is I go through all
that material and in the case obviously
of
the Everest book you know is files of
original
letters and reports I mean and then I
I create what I call work points you
know I don't read the books I don't scan
the books or skim the books I think I'd
say I mind the books you know I know for
example that I want to
deal at some point with how Edwardian
women or women during the Great War
dealt with the
the experience of death right as one
example well I know that in my head
that's there so I as I go through all
the material I start constructing these
work points and that work Point could be
anything on a theme you know
homosexuality in the 1920s or the
Buddhist science mind I mean and the
work points can become a huge number
right but then everything I then
subsequently source
I know there's a work Point sheet a
document to put it in right
and so then that's how I distill all
this Research into a manageable
set of sources and and when I write the
book I never go back unless I
specifically need to for one point or
something to the original sources and at
the same time I find Tim and you might
try this that the act of doing that kind
of unveils
the outline of the book you know in ways
I don't think you can simply I want to
write a book on Coca oh here's going to
be chapter one chapter two I mean that's
these book proposals from Publishers are
so idiotic because you can't really do
that you know the book unveils itself I
mean I'm sure you've had this experience
you think oh my god I've got to talk
about this element of his life it's
gonna be boring I'll have to cover it in
10 pages and you discover you can
actually do say all that you need to say
in a paragraph or in verse where you
discover oh my God schulte's perfect
example schulte's in one River you know
oh I knew he was involved in this rubber
crisis in World War II oh it's going to
be so boring but I got to cover it turns
out to be the most exciting part of this
career and of the book right so the
books have a way of unfolding like that
and I find and I know some other writers
no David McCulloch the great writer
incredible writer starts to write his
books before he's even finished the
research which I can't do yeah I can't
do that either I feel it's like you know
I have to have all the all the stuff
before me before I begin to assemble it
into the writing and I don't think it's
a slow process I actually write very
quickly may I ask a follow-up question
though when you have your work points do
you organize them thematically into some
type of order that you intend to follow
as you piece those points into Pros
yes and no I mean you know with the case
of into the silence for example I had to
have one whole
work Point as I call it just the pure
chronology of the battles because I was
dealing with all these men who fought
all over the place I had that just
really know what happened at each battle
but the beginning I did this research
there were 26 men
who went to Everest on those first
Expeditions 21 1922 1924
six of them missed the war Sandy Irvin
too young long staff to Old won a school
teacher another Diplomat but 20 saw the
worst of the fighting
and there were many other men and I set
out to find out where each one of those
21 Men it turned out to be had been
every single day of the four years and
four months of the first world war and I
did it wow that's an amazing task you
know it might be fun Tim when sometime
when we're not just doing this kind of
podcast if you're interested we could
get a call together for 10 minutes I
could really show you some of these work
points I really I would love my graduate
students it's a really helpful way and
then you have things pop up like for
example that that question of women
relationship to the war well you could
write a 10 pages about that and never
achieve anything like a single line
from Diana manners who said that by the
end of 1916 every boy I had ever danced
with was dead
right and you're looking for those you
know the other thing I call Tim is Wow
points this is really important
if you're reading along like I was
reading Max Hastings a great historian I
really love his books he wrote a book
about the last year the Pacific War and
the overwhelming dominance of the
Americans and one of the statistics that
just blew my mind and I'll give you this
as a quiz okay
for every four pounds of equipment
food gas bullets grenades everything
per capita the Japanese empire the sun
got to a Frontline Soldier per capita
how many pounds did we get and across 13
000 kilometers of ocean
as an American you're gonna love this
I have no idea I won't even hazardly
guess no I got mine you got to guess
give me the question one more time for
every four pounds of equipment or per
capita you know and that means and for
all the stuff they sent to the soldiers
all the stuff everything from Tokyo or
wherever it came from
for every four pounds the Japanese got
to a soldier how many pounds did America
get to a soldier okay I'm just gonna
throw a number out there I might be
overestimating I'll say 40 pounds two
tons
okay you see so when I'm reading along
like that
you know I go wow as you'd go wow and
you followed away and before you know it
you're writing a piece on Rolling Stone
about the unraveling of America and you
want to speak about how extraordinarily
powerful America was industrially in
World War II you cut you know they come
back to you they come back to you and so
yeah but the key thing I find Tim is if
you're reading and something blows your
mind that's why I call it Wow points
it's going to blow the mind of the
reader and you want to make sure that
you find a way to get all those Wow
points into your manuscript
how do you file your Wow points and or
just make these available in Word
documents yeah and like
Nancy manners I get that thing about
everybody I dance with was dead well
that would be filed away in women in the
war or something like that right got it
I'd be happy out of office hours kind of
thing you know just when you've got a
moment and we might be able to pull them
up and it's good exercise it's really
helpful oh I would love to do it that's
a very generous offer my answer is yes
it's the only way to kind of deal with
the body of material I mean I this whole
wall of my office here is books that I
bought for that one book you know wow
yes so I would love to do that that's a
very generous offer and you've been very
generous with your time I appreciate you
being so game to go two and a half hours
I could go another two and a half hours
but maybe we'll save that for a round
two if if this torture wasn't too bad no
it's been a lot of fun and you asked at
the very beginning what you did is
exactly what I was hoping you'd do it
was fun oh amazing it wasn't work it was
a conversation my friend very kind of
you oh I loved it and I hope we get to
meet in person but before then we can
certainly have a phone call I would love
to see your work points and your flow is
there anything you would like to mention
call attention to any request of the
audience you'd like to make before we
come to a close no I mean not really
it's nice that you can plug the
Magdalena book or the introduction but
other than that that's fine I I unless
there's something you want me to say no
no you've done more than enough and I
will just say thank you very much and to
everybody listening we will link to all
of the books all of the references many
many if not we'll attempt to get all the
things that were mentioned this
conversation in the show notes as per
usual at Tim dot Blog podcast
and wow Wade Davis ladies and gentlemen
and thanks to everybody for tuning in